jquery by far the world's most popular
javascript library being found on over
80 percent of the world's top 1 million
websites
that's more than four times the adoption
of angular react and view
combined it was invented back in 2006 by
john resig before most of today's junior
developers were even born he originally
wanted to call it jselect
but all the domains were taken the
popularity of jquery is driven by a
fundamental need in the web development
market
javascript is a total and we want to
write less of it furthermore
back in o6 browsers had a bunch of
interop issues jquery provided a single
api to handle the edge cases across
multiple browsers
it's so good in fact that browser
vendors of today have standardized many
of its features and ship them as native
apis
you can install it by finding the source
code on the website right click to copy
it then open dreamweaver and find all of
the html pages and paste it into a
script tag on each one your javascript
now has access to the mighty dollar sign
function
it takes a selector as its argument like
a tag name class or id it'll grab that
html from the dom
allowing you to perform actions on it in
the html we have a list of items and we
want to grab the first item in vanilla
js we'd have to use this ridiculously
long line of code to do so
in react we have to completely rewrite
our code into a component and implement
the confusing ref hook
with jquery we can use the dollar sign
to grab all the list items and then call
first to get the first one
it's easy and readable if we want to
animate it we can do that by simply
chaining a method to it and we can chain
more methods to it to register event
listeners and all kinds of other fun
stuff
declarative framework developers love to
fight each other about state management
don't make me swing on you bro
while jquery developers don't have this
problem because there's no data layer to
worry about instead you just start with
an object
shade methods to it and let the state
manage itself when it comes time to
extend jquery there's no need for
insanely complex web pack bundling or
npm packages
you can just extend its prototype with a
plugin and there's already a huge
ecosystem of plugins to get things done
quickly
as an added bonus once you've mastered
jquery you can jump into jquery mobile
and start building native apps for
windows phone and blackberry
developers of today sometimes make fun
of jquery but that's just the stuff you
have to deal with when you're the king
of javascript libraries
this has been the legend of jquery in
100 seconds if you want to see more
short videos like this hit the like
button and subscribe
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one